ELIZABETH CHOE: Pulling
together this teaching team,
I kind of felt like Nick
Fury from The Avengers.
Tapping into all these people
that I came across either
as a student, or working with.
Video production,
that was something
that we covered in the class.
It's not a solo
effort, and I think
teaching video production very
much is not a solo effort.
So Chris and I had been talking
about this for several years,
I feel like.
Just going through
your class, and then
talking about the program,
and the videos that we make.
We'd just been tossing
around these ideas.
And George and I have
worked together extensively,
she said with a heavy
sigh, on Science Out Loud.
Josh and I met at a
conference purely by accident.
And I knew you guys were
doing awesome animation work,
and that was something
that I didn't really
feel like much expertise on.
Just like storyboarding
in general,
which is really important for
students, and for everyone
really.
And then we had a couple other
guest speakers here and there.
So it was really--
so teaching something
that doesn't have an
objective answer, in physics
there's a right answer to a
problem set, for instance.
In media production or creative
writing, or anything like this,
you can't just be
like, well this
is what makes a good
answer, necessarily.
I feel like something
that helps solidify,
or helps you come to a
good feedback mechanism
for students is
to have people who
are good practitioners of
whatever media you're making.
So, you know, if you're
teaching creative writing,
hopefully you'd be a pretty
good creative writer.
If you're teaching media
production, or storyboarding,
hopefully you're a good
animator, or story boarder.
Hopefully you're a decent host.
JOSHUA GUNN: Fair to middling.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I know, right?
Tolerable.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So that
was why from the beginning
I felt like it had to be team
effort to teach this class.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I think
you had a skeleton
outline for the
course, and then you
filled in the parts, the
learning objectives for parts
that you were going to
do, and then each of us
filled in our parts, and
then we all commented
on the other people's parts.
Which was a good way to do it.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's
tricky because, its not
like a linear sort of knowledge
comprehension format where
first you learn
scripting, and then you
can learn storyboarding, and
then you can learn hosting.
That's actually how we
first approached it,
and it got really hairy because
there's so much overlap.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Why?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Why did
we approach it that way?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: No.
Why did it get hairy?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Well,
because I think Chris,
initially you wanted--
CHRIS BOEBEL: I caused
all the trouble.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What did you do?
ELIZABETH CHOE: I'm like,
well what should I talk about?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, there
was a lot of coordination
that we-- Josh and I,
especially, I think,
we felt the need to coordinate.
Because there are
things that are
similar when you're
thinking about kind
of telling a story in
animation and in live action,
but there are also things
that are different.
And we wanted to make sure
that we weren't overlapping
each other, and that we were
kind of complementary and not
repetitive or contradictory.
So I think we ended up
kind of restructuring
a little bit the first few
sessions of the course.
I'm trying to remember.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
It was interesting
because in terms of the big
picture learning objectives,
I worked with Jaime a lot,
the other course instructor.
And she has never
done video production.
She wasn't familiar
with the content.
But she's more familiar with
just instructional design
in general.
So she would ask me
all these questions
that I wouldn't necessarily
think to ask or answer,
like at the end of the
day, what are the skills
that you want people to have?
And then what are the sort of
learning objectives that you
want them to aspire to?
And those are two very
different things, right?
Because I don't really care if
they were masters of Final Cut
by the end, because that
doesn't really matter.
The objective is can you
articulate a clear story?
But she and I would
meet to sort of figure
out what are the big
picture learning objectives
that we want, and
then it was a matter
of how can we take all these
details and all these very
important plastic elements, and
pick at the most relevant ones
to match to the objectives.